nous avons toutes et tous vécu des
moments de négociation dans notre vie
que ce soit dès l'enfance auprès de nos
proches de mes professeurs ou encore à
l'âge adulte dans le monde professionnel
ou pour l'achat d'une voiture ou d'une
maison ce sont des moments particuliers
où chacun d'entre nous adopte des
stratégies nous allons peut-être faire
les yeux doux ou encore préparer des
arguments en amont ou bien encore adopté
une posture compétitive afin d'arriver à
nos fins
si ce n'est le tout en même temps
ce sont des moments désagréables pour
beaucoup d'entre nous ou nous aimerions
pouvoir favoriser une rencontre humaine
collaborative
dans le monde de l'entreprise la
dynamique concurrentielle
nous amène souvent à adopter une posture
compétitive nous devons avoir une offre
claire créer et conserver une clientèle
être payés avant des contrats pour
assurer la rentabilité financière de
l'entreprise
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme
paraît-il et si nous voulons jouer à ce
genre de comparaison un peu douteux avec
la nature je préfère encore vous
présenter le figuier étrangleur
c'est le boa constrictor de nos forêts
tropicales c'est un maître dans l'art de
la prédation
il n'est sûr les plus être branche de
son hôte
et durant des années va tranquillement
laissé ses racines tombante
étranglé l'arbre en dessous
et le tout sous nos yeux ébahis par son
design magnifique à vous
mais alors
est il possible en entreprise de changé
ces rapports nous le savons la
collaboration est bien plus efficace que
la compétition mais concrètement comment
la mettre en place
je suis christelle fournier
accompagnatrice en permaculture et
spécialiste en intelligence collective
et j'ai fondé une entreprise incorporée
pour mes activités professionnelles pour
celles et ceux qui connaissent la
permaculture c'est assez contradictoire
et ce à juste titre comment puis-je
prôner la collaboration que nous invite
à adopter la permaculture et en même
temps avoir des objectifs je me cachais
de rentabilité financière
en gros comment être un bois ou plutôt
un figuier nom et wrangler
en fait je me suis moi même posé la
question
d'ailleurs savez vous ce qu'est la
permaculture
certains d'entre vous connaissent
peut-être avez-vous déjà vu ce genre
d'image
en fait la permaculture est à la fois
une philosophie et une méthodologie
d'applications pour mettre en place des
projets écologiques qui s'inspirent
souvent des écosystèmes naturels
mais au delà de ce seuil la permaculture
nous invite aussi à revisiter nos façons
de faire ensemble
je laime beaucoup celle le but ultime de
l'agriculture n'est pas de faire pousser
des récoltes mais la culture et
l'accomplissement des êtres humains
fukuoka était à la fois un agriculteur
scientifique et penseur japonais qui a
énormément inspiré la discipline
mais revenons-en à la permaculture comme
thème je vais vous faire une mini
définition rapide pour qu'on soit tous
d'accord
en gros la permaculture s'appuie sur
trois principes éthiques de base le
premier prendre soin de la terre donc
leur ont versé d'ailleurs souvent à
celui là qu'on associe la permaculture
le second c'est prendre soin des humains
prendre soin de soi du groupe des autres
nous sommes dans le rouge et puis le
dernier s'est partagé équitable
le rond orange
partager la gouvernance des ressources
la transmission des savoirs et bien
d'autres choses
et alors ce qui est magique c'est que si
nous réunissons seulement le prendre
soin de l'humain est partagée
équitablement nous sommes dans ce que
nous appelons la permaculture sociale
et alors et bien en fait la permaculture
social nous invite à réinventer nos
façons de faire ensemble
tel un laboratoire à l'expérimenter pour
cela il existe de nombreux outils de
mobilisation de l'intelligence
collective
en gros l'idée c'est de se dire pourquoi
ne pas essayer ensemble d'augmenter la
tarte pour que chacun puisse avoir une
part qui répondent à ses besoins
savez vous ce qu'est l'intelligence
collective
avez-vous déjà vécu des moments de
mobilisation de l'intelligence
collective
en fait très certainement
mais pas forcément là où vous vous y
attendez
d'ailleurs entendons nous sur les termes
l'intelligence collective n'est pas la
communication collective la
communication collective sans doute vous
l'avez vécu déjà dans le monde de
l'entreprise dans les études le travail
en groupe c'est quoi nous arrivons avec
une posture d' écoute empathique ouverte
et nous écoutons les arguments de chacun
ensuite les propositions de chacun et de
là nous choisissons la meilleure option
nous sommes dans le paradigme du ou un
choix ou un autre ou un autre
l'intelligence collective c'est tout
autre chose cette fois l'objectif est de
créer une idée nouvelle où seuls nous
aurions jamais pensé
nous allons encore une fois adopté une
posture d'écouté active de bienveillance
mais nous allons venir en faisant
confiance au groupe sans avoir d'idée
préconçue sur le résultat final
il faut se déposer nous sommes dans le
paradigme du est une idée et une autre
et une autre pour créer une idée
nouvelle
et donc à partir de là
pensez-vous avoir déjà vécu des moments
de mobilisation de l'intelligence
collective
en fait pour les moments les plus connus
de tout un chacun nous appelons à voir
certains jeux d'equipe certaines danses
à plusieurs les jam musicaux
particulièrement le jazz ou encore des
matchs d'improvisation
aujourd'hui je souhaite vous faire
découvrir un outil de mobilisation de
l'intelligence collective
qui accompagne la négociation que j'ai
co développés qui fonctionne et qui me
surprend
j'espère qu'il sera ré approprier par
d'autres et qu'il sera bonifiée est tant
mieux
tout a commencé
avec les colibris à lyon pour celles et
ceux qui connaissent nous étions un
groupe de bénévoles et nous souhaitions
faire découvrir l'agroécologie via
l'action à des citadins
pour cela nous avons développé le projet
adopte une courge donc sur la gauche
c'est moi qui suit dessinée
[Rires]
et l'idée était de dire nous allons
aller dans un organisme maraîchers sur
les terres d'un maraîcher qui nous
prêtait une parcelle
qui entretenait non il d'abord préparer
le sol et ensuite entretenu les courges
durant la saison de façon sporadique
nous amenions des personnes de la ville
venir entretenir des courges et
découvrir le monde de l'agriculture
nous nous sommes alors posé la question
de l'échangé comment un hâle allions
nous créer un échange et un contrat avec
l'organisme maraîchers nous étions tous
bénévoles et puis l'idée d'un contrat
contraignant faisait aucun sens c'est l
organisme maraîchers le plus généreux
dans le projet
juridiquement on va nulle part
donc nous avons oublié cette idée
nous avons un petit peu fait nos devoirs
et découvert qu'un organisme un
laboratoire citoyens à lyon faisait ce
qu'on appelle des cadres de réciprocité
c'est le laboratoire la mine qui déjà
avait cette idée de faire rencontrer des
organismes biya une rencontre amicale et
non contraignante nous avons décidé de
reprendre une partie de ces de ses
écrits pour développer des accords de
réciprocité
l'idée était que l'accord soit amical
collaboratif non contraignant et
évolutif
sur six mois il était fort possible que
le projet évolue
nous avons semblé très professionnel aux
yeux de l'organisme maraîchers et ils
ont eu confiance
nous savons aujourd'hui que le projet a
existé durant quatre ans après nous
grâce entre autres à ce type d'accord
quelques années après avec l'un des amis
avec qui nous avions fondé ce travail
d'adopter une courge nous avons décidé
de créer une formation de neuf jours en
agroécologie en permaculture
la question des échanges est revenu nous
allions encore une fois aller sur des
terres d'organismes maraîchers
mais nous voulions cette fois y inclure
une notion de prix les payer via ce que
nous allions gagner
de l'autre côté nous nous sommes posés
l'axé là nous nous sommes posés la
réflexion à l'accès universel à la
formation comment rendre cette
information
accessible à toutes et tous pour cela
nous avons décidé de créer des tarifs
équitable qui est invité à chaque
participant à réfléchir sur ce qui
pouvait donner en fonction de nos
propres besoins financiers également
tout le monde était au courant autant
les organismes de maraîchers que les
participants nous avons essayé de faire
le tout en transparence et cela a
fonctionné
nous avons pu être payés
de façon juste et les organismes
maraîcher à notre grande surprise ont
tous refusé la contribution financière
nous leur sommes aujourd'hui encore très
reconnaissant
mais revenons-en dans le monde de
l'entreprise
en tant qu'entrepreneur je me suis posé
la question de comment négocier avec mes
clients
souvent en fait on a des cours
d'entrepreneuriat où on nous explique
comment préparer la négociation ont fait
des petits tableaux
on essaye de d'avoir des arguments
avec aussi des propositions de rabais de
valorisation de ce qu'on fait c'est à la
fois très pertinent et complètement
artificielle en fait en tout cas à moi
ça ne me correspond pas du tout je me
suis alors demandé était possible de
venir
sans préparer la négociation est juste
me mettre dans une posture de confiance
dans la rencontre en gros ce que j'avais
déjà appris en termes d'intelligence
collective j'ai donc ressorti mes petits
accords de réciprocité
et j'ai proposé à mes clientes
en fait en général sacré de l'engouement
de l' enthousiasme car nous savons que
nous allons répondre aux projets communs
par contre ne savons pas encore comment
mais nous sommes sûrs que nous allons
rencontrer une façon
souvent les premiers accords c'est moi
qui les écrit aux trois quarts puisque
c'est assez nouveau et puis je laisse
les parties blanches en leur disant que
ce sont les partis qui doit essayer de
créer pour justement créer cette
nouvelle réalité et la chose très
surprenante c'est qu'à chaque fois mes
clientes me sort des idées auxquelles je
n'aurais jamais pensé ça a été le cas d'
hec montréal qui lors du premiers
accords que nous avons signés a décidé
parmi les contributions de clarifier
l'accord de réciprocité comme tel de
réécrire les termes aujourd'hui c'est le
c'est l'accord que j'utilise au
quotidien
parmi les contributions que je peux
encore utilisé il ya des lieux physiques
où je peux donner des ateliers
conférence il ya également
une aide à la communication aux besoins
et pour finir j'ai même le droit au
service du doubs là si je tombe enceinte
parmi
les observations empiriques que j'ai pu
faire
lorsqu'il ya un second d'accords de
réciprocité de réciprocité signé mes
clientes sont parties prenantes elles
construisent le deuxième accord elles
sont proactives de plus les échéanciers
financiers que nous nous étions fixés
sont toujours respectés et ça c'est pas
gagné en entreprise
des fois ça a été en ma faveur qui a une
une rehausse de la de la financière et
pour finir ce sont de loin de mes
meilleures ambassadrices
et maintenant
et bien favorisons le changement de
paradigme
essayons ozon co créons des nouveaux
outils tels à laboratoire avec des
échecs des réussites partageons les nous
sommes nombreux et nombreuses déjà a co
créé aller dans ce sens entre autres
parmi le monde des communs bref comment
le risque ensemble de co-créer le monde
socio écologique qui nous inspire
[Applaudissements]